würden sie auch noch weitere AKW im
Betrieb nehmen die auch teilweise gerade
im Rückbau sind oder neue sogar dazu
bauen was ist die Idee also die
Kernkraftwerken der alten Generation
werden nicht mehr gebaut auch mutmaßlich
in Europa in Zukunft nicht mehr es geht
schon um die Frage das machen die
Amerikaner die Generator die
Kernkraftwerke der neuen Generation
darüber nachzudenken da werden wir als
FDP offen übrigens auch das ist kein
Geheimnis das hat glaube ich die FDP im
April auf ihrem letzten Bundestag
beschlossen also alles kein Geheimnis
wir haben da energiepolitische
Vorstellung die sind teilweise nicht
deckungsgleich mit denen sowohl günstig
oder SPD und der Grünen teilweise sogar
der Union die Union
auch anders gesehen da geht's aber nicht
ich betone aber technisch da genau sein
müssen um die alten Kern Spalt
Redakteuren der Vergangenheit sondern
kleinere Reaktoren der Zukunft die in
anderen Teilen der Welt gebaut werden
auch darüber muss man nachdenken ich
finde Deutschland war super darin zu
sagen wo wir aussteigen wir müssen auch
sagen wobei einsteigen
[Musik]